okay this is gonna be a fun one I have a
Craig hi I'm John
we're gonna watch Lily Reinhart from
Riverdale revealing speech about body
image glamour Woman of the Year 2018
this is a topper war two requests from
aniseh Alaba she basically said that she
wants the video do some of the talking
this is one of her favorite videos about
women's insecurities about their bodies
in general and on social media I just
want to know for guys if this goes
through your mind as much as it does for
girls a hundred percent tell you
abso-freakin'-lutely it is the same
anxieties not this verbatim think it's
done the same level and it woman must go
through but a hundred percent it's even
harder her shoes it's harder for us and
it is John you're being insolent being
absolutely a hundred percent not
sarcastic
[Music]
it's great
for the past year I've been quietly
trying to navigate my weight I faced
criticism in the past we're talking
about my body image but and I was
exposed to young women smaller that I
was telling me that they needed to lose
weight
I felt this strange constant struggle of
having to live up to the expectation of
the appearance that I had already
established how my body looks so
different over the course of one day and
why do I feel like I need to apologize
to the world for my ever changing self
I want the world to think that I was
catfishing them with my appearance close
myself out to be a certain size shape
when clearly my body was changing so I
told myself I could see this change
reflections don't lie I get that is that
just dysmorphia or is this the normal
part of being a woman that no one really
talks about I think about when I have
kids in the future and well my daughter
be self-conscious about any weight will
she feel the need to explain her body or
justify will she feel the same me that I
do now to apologize to peers and say oh
my body doesn't usually look like this
because how ridiculous is it
that we even think about explaining the
nature of our bodies to other people but
it's because we don't want them to judge
us because judgment and criticism have
always existed it's just that now
everyone can be a critic and share it
publicly without hesitation
here's what she really looks like I
wanted to see the flaws can't imagine
being a woman on the air there is no way
in hell that has young women digesting
this media we want to all going to try
and hide those parts of ourselves
we are conditioned to feel ashamed or
embarrassed about certain parts of
ourselves the world is not going to
reform we can't rely on those who profit
from our perceived flaws to change their
ways
there is no easy fix to the idea the
ideas of women that have existed for
hundreds of years so that leaves us with
one option ourselves you are helping
that we have been forever told to hide
yeah so as a first step I encourage you
to find a healthy balance between
expressing the natural vulnerable side
shoots and red carpets I think it's much
more important some days I feel strong
and confident
I started to purge myself
remind yourself that this perfect world
you see so many different filters so do
not set impossible goals of meeting
those fake standards we are all
perfectly beautiful so let's embrace
that and practice that in a healthy way
there is a massive worldwide community
of women who are rooting for beauty to
be recognized in every shape and color
that become in I mean events like this
glamorous of it are a part of that
movement so embracing your natural
beauty does not exclude
you can be naturally beautiful with acne
or scars cellulite or curves so let's
celebrate each other and ourselves as we
are as we will be
that's great
I'm gonna watch Riverdale now yep that's
yeah she was there to promote the show
and they were like hey everyone's sexy
on Rivard I was really impressed with
their speech and I was impressed with
the connection she was even making with
the camera I saw the teleprompter in the
background that had this whole speech is
irrelevant now it's fake news big news I
can't speak for women no right I can't I
can't I can definitely take the
direction of what Nyssa was asking about
from the guys perspective and speak on
this and I've said it countless times
bring this up again one time I was being
interviewed for something and I was
asked a question I've never been asked
before which was who has it hardest on
the Internet and it was the quickest
answer I've ever had which was women I
can't imagine what it's like to be a
woman online the standard of what
society generally expects for a woman
and hand on the harsh unfair criticism
that comes I can empathize in so many
ways I can relate in so many ways but I
can never truly understand with that
being said though I was nodding my head
because I'm like I might not be a woman
but I definitely go through all that
yeah like a hundred percent I do I've
been definitely not to the extreme
because let's face it in society guys
can get away with a lot more than and
then women can you can be like a really
overweight guy but carry yourself a
certain way get away with it you know
whereas usually a woman who is like
overweight lends itself for some reason
to be criticized a lot more I've been
told that I probably have body
dysmorphia everything down to like my
hair the way I just generally look at it
I always feel like generally feel like I
had this like unattractive appearance
YouTube did not necessarily help out
with any of that you know when this
channel was first growing a lot I was a
lot more overweight people were not shy
to point that out you know and as a guy
you could do things to embrace that you
know like taking off your shirt becomes
funny now okay and how I like embracing
that quality but truth be told I was
very much instant
and still am pretty insecure about my
weight for filming I've been drinking
this rain which has made me bloated so I
found myself like naturally trying not
to let my stomach stick out because I
feel like uncomfortable about my belly
we have a mirror right over here that I
try not to be so look at home filming
because every time I look over my eyes
immediately just go to my stomach oh
dear you're self-conscious areas I have
like crazy wild curly hair
I feel like 99% of the time no one can
really tell what looks different about
it but like people can understand that
difficulties of having curly hair are
people wouldn't curly hair right I
always get into long conversations about
the struggles of curly hair and most
people really got her hair looks the
same to me but truthfully like it to me
it looks completely different every
single day it's like a fingerprint yeah
who's the same it really it really does
but every day I'm very self-conscious
about my even if I have a shaved head I
feel like that I look at the shape of my
head so I used to go by the Rhine right
personality great help surprisingly a
lot like Ryan right overcompensating is
an entire ego but really that was it
felt that I don't know what it's like
being a woman so I can't say that I
wonder % get it by speaking from a guy's
perspective I'll admit to it because I
honestly think a lot of guys deal with
it and a lot of guys just don't talk
about it yeah it's a real real thing
yeah it's the same kind of position for
me as I can't say that it's the same cuz
I know it's not the same but there are
shut up John look at you there your
beautiful long hair and your natural
skin eNOS wasn't always through you my
natural screw you dar I did it I just
did it right I think there are shades of
this that we all experienced and the
thing is the reason I definitely believe
that women have probably just a more
multifaceted view on this and probably a
more intense experience with it the
paradigm that we grow up in I feel like
everybody is incentivized to look good
everybody can be made to feel
self-conscious from a very young age
about their body for various reason I
mean like if you're chubby pea I think
kids are just going to find you and
start making fun of you but there are
other things too that you see you know
we see images
movies and stuff or magazines of like
the perfect body and then we all have
that perfect in mind that we feel like
we need to get to and so much of that is
arbitrary and so much of it is just
somebody's taste or the way advertising
or whatever the force is have shaped you
know our social society and for women
and for girls especially I feel like you
grow up being looked at and judged by
for your appearance by more people from
a younger age for much more time and
there's also just a good amount of poor
behavior that goes unchecked and
unnoticed some of the time and so yeah I
think all those things coming together
create a uniquely different experience
of body dysmorphia body image for men
and women but yeah in the general I mean
the I was sitting here relating heavily
to what she's saying because I've new
lungs you know had my body image issues
I mean you know when I was a kid people
would make fun of me for being fat all
the time so like I I grew up with that
and that's led me different places I
mean I'm doing better now but it's
affected the way I eat it's affected the
way I look at my body it's affected the
way I exercised affected the way I
socialize yeah it's a hard thing to
forget about you know especially yeah if
you're out in a social situation and you
don't feel right about your body today
that can change the whole tone that your
mind is you know communicating through I
don't know if it's just like my own
algorithm hood in life or whatever I
attracted I feel like usually a big
topic of conversation seems like
everywhere since I was a little kid has
been losing weight you know lose weight
has been such a focus and I honestly
didn't realize how much maybe images
I've seen on television or movies and I
started noticing it with social media
especially the general by types that the
certain women aspire to - for like oh
that's the perfect body I feel like for
guys generally it's to get cut yeah
exactly you know that like every 3 M
muscle yeah and then it's just about
what size muscles do you yeah no
seriously yeah that seems to be the
conversation that's why I think the the
embrace of dad bod is there's less
sexual components for men than there are
for women the thing with like my stomach
is especially this is like I'll get
bloated in my face and I'll get blue my
stomach and I feel like I have like
major bloating issues but then something
was brought up to me the topic of
cortisol in your stomach and how that
can bloat you up and cause you to retain
even like more water weight so it's like
this idea that whenever I get a little
stressed about being a little bloated I
get bloated more because I'm stressed
how can you believe it so yeah I have
the thing to or she was talking about of
when you explained like if I'm not
feeling like on top of my weight I'll
constantly say something cuz I feel like
someone's looking at a body to explain
away like all uploaded right now because
I'm trying to defuse a bomb of judgment
or something but all I'm doing is
drawing attention to it and another
thing I'm very I've been very guilty of
the lines are to overweight or to stew
and healthily skinny most people I meet
usually have the issue not a being too
skinny but a feeling overweight and
wanting to lose weight and being jealous
of those people who are really skinny so
I tend to fall into that camp the people
who are jealous of the skin I'm guilty
of what she's talking about right here
of someone usually complain about like I
just keep eating and I can't seem to
gain any weight and my mind goes to off
my mind goes to its genetic oh gosh yeah
rather have that problem like I do you
tend to go there it's kind of a
subconscious reaction I don't say that
to the person oh boy I think it's a gift
that the thought does come into my mind
of that I have lacked empathy on
understanding whether that struggle must
be like so that's something that I
should definitely apply more I don't
know if I just put myself in a Liam
Neeson situation I find a skinny burn
we're living a weird culture now where
if you admit to a past thought even
though your your whole point just to be
like it's not cool to think this would
be your judge it's weird to bring up a
faux pas that you've corrected already
because either way it's new to everyone
yeah
I think it also speaks to the part of us
that we always envied the problems we
don't have we would always trade our
problems I usually I feel like maybe
somebody who has that skinny metabolism
can't gain weight would probably go well
if I was overweight I could just work
out and you know I would have control
where you know you don't feel as trapped
in this situation I'm sure somebody's
struggling with the opposite feels
similarly trapped for different reasons
yeah from my guy perspective I've never
really been like most dudes in the sense
of I feel like you know I just getting
in no woman no matter what size or shape
she is you can I all I can find that
person attractive just getting to know
them you know what I mean and it's magic
yeah yeah personalities like generally
speaking my girlfriend I prefer without
makeup yeah man there are a lot of ways
to be total alive she's just listening
to the door right now just worked back
up on good tomorrow watches the video so
if you're looking for the perfect body
just model it after Greg's girl she's
got a great body
she's been on top of it man waking up at
like 5:00 in the before in the morning
on the weekdays and going in the gym I
don't know how she does it Wow I'm
waking up when she's leaving to go to
work top of that's gonna be fascinating
cuz like you're a pretty early riser so
to have somebody even earlier
fascinating great ass
thanks man now you I know you ever meet
my girlfriend check out her but I'm like
yeah you're no reason to suspect with
the idea sound carries this is great
there's links to the real rejects cuz
she's on TV alright there's there some
episodes of Riverdale on our page not
irrelevant
alright Anissa thank you so much you
rock appreciate you being vulnerable
with us and asking us a personal
question
you've gotten personal it's nice to get
real sometimes yeah are tal
oh ho this is going to Vegas next week
Vegas baby Vegas she's gonna have a
great time no money boy you gonna make
it rain on some stripper John trying to
watch y'all a dollar bill sign
you can't you gotta make it rain on that
on some dancers there you go
YouTube isn't why you talking about real
things okay then there's fine one of
those guys who clicks the cards at you I
don't know what to do subscribe quick
bounce will see you